actually sir I would usually just write
UV right which looks like this x squared
on to log X to the N okay
however this is a definite integral
right so in fact I should write this
happy with that yeah yeah okay so then
I've got by minus V to u right good to
go have a look you've got there's V
there and then there's do you which it
is okay let's let's just write this out
okay now we saw very careful okay there
was something wrong with this question
right at the beginning when I wrote it
down and hopefully now that you look at
this second line something is kind of
staring you in the face even more
obviously okay what's wrong with this
question there's something freaking
freed about yeah
okay so before you start doing anything
spiritual by parts or anything you look
at this you say on a second hold on a
second this function here is not defined
there yeah it's not to find a that's
usually a bit of a problem for behavior
right because especially when you get to
here you're like whoa what okay I
how am I supposed to evaluate this thing
now this sort of leads to a bigger
question
the what is what we say oh it's not it's
not to find that okay there are
different ways that a function can be
not defined okay you could for example
have a function a you just arbitrarily
say okay I'm gonna put a hole there I'm
just gonna say oh I wanted to point here
and here and so there's like a straight
line and it's got a hollow circle in the
middle okay then you've got acid hurts
you have other kinds of things that
create discontinuities okay
he's one other T's for you and I'm gonna
do the maths of it now I've got two
examples of my sleeve that demonstrate
this this stop discontinuity in this
function as it happens just know it all
stop
working out the bigger question the
bigger question is what's the area to
find between that curve and the x-axis
right because I'm integrating with
respect to X along some X pounders okay
now it seems a little bit
counterintuitive that you could have say
for example I think one of the examples
that we did was something like how you
had sex possibly okay so this is what we
would call an unbounded region okay like
this thing here underneath the axis okay
but as it happens mathematically there's
no reason why you can't actually
evaluate that area that area I mean it
does go on forever but because of the
way that it goes on forever
there is limiting behavior that you can
take advantage of in the same way that
if I talk about 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8
plus 1/16 that thing never ends it's
unbounded but we know it's very
well-defined but that infinite series is
equal to yeah now you've got a similar
kind of thing happening at the moment
okay
I'm not gonna dig all the way into it
I'm just gonna get enough of an answer
to proceed from here but if you're
curious like I said I'll pull out my
examples which will show you no there's
no problem here
I'll even show you the picture of what
this ends up being and that it is indeed
well-defined
okay so temporarily look at this don't
read out think about what this thing is
going to be it's a it's a product right
so if you're thinking about what this
function looks like if I gave pose this
to you as like I say a graphing problem
okay let's think about boundaries one at
a time
let's look at the top powdery top okay
you've got that's gonna be 1/2 what's
this guy gonna be it's zero so the first
human right is zero
are you thinking that the lower bound
ready now we have this problem that we
encounter okay which rigorously should
be sort of sorted out with limits okay
because even though I can't get to there
at zero I can think about what happens
the limit as X approaches zero now think
about that for a second
the limit as X approaches zero one of
these two things doing
once approaching well this guy's
approaching zero right
and this guy's approaching negative
infinity cuz sudden you think that the
mark-up is some racing down okay now I
won't again like I said I'll go dig into
the calculus but if you actually go
ahead to valuate it turns out you get to
zero it's a bit counterintuitive okay
but again that the examples to sort of
prove rigorously why for now stay with
me and be content for a fact that this
thing it does absolute that evaluate to
zero with minutes and I'll show you it's
a version of effects this particular one
isn't like this this powers a bit
arbitrary that kind of thing but there's
a famous proof that's very very similar
to this and all of the ones that we're
talking about here they're in this
family of of being unbounded puppy
well-defined ed finite they are all part
of this family on famous Cruz and I have
a couple up my sleeve okay but I don't
welcome to class here let's just take
that for now and run with them okay what
are we having in here we need to sort of
tidy this up a little bit so we yeah
okay good so I've got a constant van M
is closer to 802 is it closer so if I
pull that guy out that deals with these
two and then in addition to that I can
actually cancel it is right which leaves
me with X log X and minus 1 DX which is
exactly what I want exactly what I would
cuz that guy there is I am but so what
was that result I was trying to prove
before I antique malls we're there okay
part one Donna dusted out of the way
okay yeah he's that that in fact apart
from this like weird little discussion
that we had which I hope you kids sort
of hold your breath on and will resolve
later
apart from that little weed bit there's
already no isn't it we identified out
you and I D be this sort of came out and
this is usually
when we stop it's kinda where you have
to stop because if it's indefinite like
what are you gonna do give me a
particular value of an or something like
that then I can watch you're talking
about this component no I don't because
if you think about what this will become
how it changes as you climb down the
ladder it's always going to become this
every single time every single time cuz
think about what will be here right this
this integral from nought to one and
then you're gonna have this guy right
but every time you do it thank God stays
the same stays the same every time it's
this guy that changes and then it keeps
on being zero all the way down that's
the whole point of the recurrence
relation okay one of the reasons I know
is I'm machine tested and so I know
that's the X okay
all right now please what starts
together take go in a different
direction
this is a recurrence relation but
there's an integral baked into it and we
sort of noticed this is a bit we need to
find into row in terms of another
integral so it's kind of this circular
definition I want to get away from there
which is why part two says if you
haven't written it down already write an
expression for I of n that does not
contain any tools and there's need to go
right there
okay so if you recall the I think the
first example we started with a very
very first one for recurrence relations
it might have been something like this I
think that was it right and then we
looked at that we actually evaluated it
we saw integration by part acted twice
and then we thought cool now I could
generalize now I can get a power of n
and we did that but do you recall at
some point here as we are working
through right pretty integration by
parts that we did integration by parts
again and then you got down to some
integral where you like oh I can just
work out where this integral is and then
it's like cool there are normal
integrals there I just had this air
today
the bottom and there's lots of X's of e
to the exes but it's done all
integration is finished okay so I had to
do two steps to do that in this case I'm
gonna have to do this n steps so you're
like how long is this proof going to be
okay but because of the the sort of the
predictability of what a recurrence
relation is I can form a pattern and I
actually I can do or in steps is I'm not
to demonstrate